how do you deal with nurse like before a
game
um it depends like if I if I'm
confident in the openness that I'm
playing then I rarely
that I'm rarely nervous
that's all uh
I mean to give an example
um
I was a little bit worried before
playing Corona now and in like
I was
thinking
after I beat truck parts like
I kind of wanted to to play a solid game
there um
and
I was a little bit I don't know I was a
little bit worried
um although I I don't know I just looked
at
the
uh
stuff that people prepare for which is
mainly like World Championships
preparations some some variations of
that in
in the Marshall and I was just thinking
like oh the market is awesome okay I
have no worries for this game whatsoever
huh
so I think yeah for me that's always
um it's always helpful I feel good about
good about the openings but I'm I'm
really nervous I do get nervous
sometimes during the game like if I miss
something or
whatever then I just try to calm down
like
sometimes just take a few seconds to
focus on your breathing is is a good
thing but I try to I try to remember
during during that at least once again
um and you can
it can help
one thing that has impressed me
tremendously was your mood it's all
before the two World Championship played
I mean and I thought that could be a
very stressful moment you seem to be
enjoying you know just in good mood I
remember especially when you had to play
Colorado I was basically shocked
listening to it it's gonna be a fun day
we're gonna go and play some chess well
I mean I just played
like being able to play rapid chess was
just a thrill I understand and
I don't know yeah for most for both of
those
for both of those
tie breaks that was just
thrilled to play rapid and I was not
the least bit worried that I was gonna
lose oh someone would make the argument
well in three hours time you could have
lost the world championship to a weaker
play but didn't cross your mind yeah but
I don't know I didn't think about it
that way I was just feeling feeling good
also like both before those
tyrex I've also like had no problem
sleeping
whatsoever
it was very um
it was very
um it was very good uh